it's certainly a happy day for britney
spears's mom lynne this is just a
groundbreaking day who's speaking out
after the latest update in her
daughter's ongoing conservatorship
battle on thursday brittany's attorney
confirmed to et that her father and
conservator jamie spears is willing to
permanently step down what he's saying
in what he just follows in court is that
he is willing to step down in the best
interests of britney spears however he
wants to talk to all the parties and he
wants to get a plan in place to make
sure it's done in a what he calls
respectable way that's good for britney
spears now lynn is reacting in a
statement obtained by e.t her attorney
tells us quote lynn spears is pleased
jaime has agreed to step down lynn
entered into this conservatorship to
protect her daughter almost three years
ago she has accomplished what she set
out to do she will have no further
comment
things have really heated up between
jamie and lynn spears
and it's getting pretty nasty in the
latest court filing jamie spears really
attacked lin spears for saying quote
false statements about him and um he's
really going after her not only as a
person in terms of what she said but
also claiming that she's been a horrible
mother all of these years and on the on
vice versa lynn spears has said the same
thing about jamie that he's been a
horrible father so what is the truth is
the question with jamie it's important
to note that while he's agreed to step
down as conservator he is not resigning
according to tmz court documents filed
by jaime say in part quote there are in
fact no actual grounds for suspending or
removing mr spears as conservator of the
estate nevertheless even as mr spears is
the unremitting target of unjustified
attacks he does not believe that a
public battle with his daughter over his
continuing service as her conservator
would be in her best interests jaime
says that he'll work with britney's new
attorney matthew rosengart so there's a
quote orderly transition to a new
conservator there's no current timeline
for that transition e.t spoke with
rosengart in july less than two weeks
ago we pledged
that after 13 years of the status quo
my firm and i would move aggressively
and expeditiously
to file a petition to suspend
and remove james p spears in court docs
obtained by e.t that same month lin said
she became a participant in britney's
conservatorship in may 2019 to quote
ensure that everything in my daughter's
life was handled in the best interests
of my daughter the conservative which i
did not believe at the time and i still
do not today to be the case lynn also
alleges that jaime has used quote
microscopic control over brittany and
says her ex-husband is quote incapable
of putting britney's interests ahead of
his own as for what's next well seems
the spears family is going to have to
come together so what jamie spears is
asking
in terms of next steps is for all of the
interested parties uh involved in this
britney spears attorney lin spears to
get together and kind of have a
discussion in terms of what the next
step should be